and today
it's the hydration trend that even has
the new york times writing about
it's called the motivational water jug
it's
all over instagram chrissy teigen was an
early fan
that was ross matthews i have to say
when i started my weight loss journey i
got one of these and oh
and i drink it every single day a gallon
of it the whole gallon
well for people who are a little
intimidated like myself to drink an
entire gallon it also comes in 32 ounces
and 64 ounces what is that's what i just
ordered okay what i like about this is
if you can see on the side it says
little like um
motivational things like you're doing it
keep going chuggalog look
things like that which um i actually
found i find it very encouraging joy the
nutritionist
remember she was here the other day
saying that the amount of water you're
supposed to drink
is your weight on a scale divided in
half and then that's the ounces so
i'm up to like 70 ounces and you do the
math that's 140 pounds okay yeah i just
did it yeah
i want to show you this soma
water filter uh picture rozzy
this is like the chicest water thing
i've ever seen in my life when i saw
this my eyes literally went like this
i was like what is this this is so
pretty
and as someone who designs things for
the kitchen now
i was totally inspired okay i'm obsessed
with the wood against the white
and the cookie do you all see this this
is like the most beautiful water filter
i've ever seen
it also comes in black and it's really
pretty um in that
uh tone as well so this picture
is 39 and i'm a very money conscientious
person i don't like to pitch things that
are too expensive
and then you can get two filters for 25
which should last a while but for 55
you get a year's worth of filters
delivered to your door on time and you
don't even need to think about it
and you know everybody says that
drinking water is like the key to health
so this could sit out
you could have your filters and you
could drink you know a specialized
healthy water in a beautiful
um component by soma this is so chic i'm
gonna put it in the center of the table
look at that my centerpiece
bam it is so important to
hydrate obviously on the heels of this
wonderful show
and how we can take better care of
ourselves this is so
vital and crucial this is
water and ross how did we get this one
it's jason momoa's company and his
mission is to cut down on single-use
plastics that clogs up all our oceans so
we put it in a can
i mean this recyclable feel good
eco-friendly choice is just fantastic
thank you jason momoa for making the
world a better place in so many ways
you should make jason mimosas next thank
you
this is t java it's hard to overstate
the importance this tea has in my life
you know when i'm constantly drinking on
this show out of a mug
this is what i'm drinking my first
thought in the morning
is not anything but this how fast
can i get this down my pie hole
and it really is the thing
that i look forward to every day
all day long and then at about four or
five or six i'm like you need to sleep
you're beyond you're cut off i'm all
about it like i'm almost done i just
opened it this is delish
they're a brand that i can't promote
enough
and um it's coming out of my pores ross
understood
yeah filling the tea